but
in this landscape of um
pharma companies they make a lot of
money
some people are worried about the impact
of those com you know
a big pharma on the landscape of human
trauma
yeah yeah so this of course some
companies could do good
but that's not inherent like um
many of these companies are not
optimizing for good they're optimizing
from profit exactly
exactly so how do you um
does this uh rise of for-profit pharma
companies were
you how do you navigate it do we still
have for-profit companies that
basically uh do what uh maps does which
is like
fight the good fight for the benefit of
humanity like what like how do we
proceed in this in landscape or work
where drugs can make a lot of money
yeah well
i am concerned overall i think the rise
of the for-profit
companies we have to realize is a sign
of success
that we have overcome
the regulatory prohibitions we've
overcome
a lot of the public attitudes that are
against it we've demonstrated some
success so the rise of the for-profit
companies
are a sign of the progress that we've
made on the other hand turning things
over to profit maximizing companies
the big concern is that they're going to
try to
minimize the amount of therapy and make
it so the cost is less so insurance
companies are more likely to cover it
and then that they just sell the most
drugs
the other thing we've seen as an example
of this is s
ketamine by johnson johnson for
depression and it's done by a profit
maximizing company
they don't know anything about
psychedelic psychotherapy or
psychotherapy at all
and so they've gotten approval for
s-ketamine on the basis of it's just a
pharmacological treatment
and it's not delivered with therapy the
results fade pretty quickly
so you need to get more ketamine and so
it's
designed in a way to maximize the
profits for the
pharmaceutical company but it doesn't
maximize patient outcomes
what we're seeing though in these
various clinics that are being set up is
that a lot of people are realizing
that it works better with therapy
and so the clinics are run by people
that are therapists so that when they
provide therapy they're making more
money and and then you need less
ketamine
also ketamine itself s ketamine is a
isomer of ketamine that's been patented
for depression
and they sell it for hundreds of dollars
but ketamine itself
is one of the world's essential
medicines it's off patent it's been
around for a long time it was the main
battlefield anesthetic in vietnam
and it's only a few bucks because it's
generic so
a lot of the ketamine clinics are saying
great thank you
johnson johnson you've helped
demonstrate that ketamine is good for
depression but we're not going to buy it
from you
we're going to buy it for a few bucks
and we're going to add therapy to it
now there's a bunch of ketamine mills
you could say that are that are
just prescribing the ketamine and people
are making a lot of money there
so i am worried about that i think the
best thing that we can do
is create an alternative narrative
a different kind of example we can lead
by example we can't make
for-profit companies into benefit
corporations
unless they want to do that we can't
make them to you know really
maximize patient outcomes but if we
create an example
of something that's different the hope
is that
people gravitate towards that and some
of the other companies like even now we
have
exxon and other these uh companies oil
companies saying oh we're big into
alternative energy
and we're you know and that starts with
companies that
show an example that uh then
communicates to the public that this is
something
exciting and then they demand of the
same of exxon and so on
the public demands and you could say the
same thing for
the public demanding the the big pharma
to uh to optimize for benefit versus
optimize
for profit and maybe giving power to the
therapists
more power to the therapist more power
to the doctors that ultimately
uh want i think
incentives are interesting but i think
doctors ultimately
care more because they're in direct
contact with humans
they want to make people better it's not
you know sure they want to make money
but they ultimately want to make people
feel better
because they get to look at people and
it's so joyful
to make people feel better at the end of
the day so giving more power to them
is also perhaps one of the ways that you
then
incentivize uh the the pharma companies
that are
trying to do good uh because the doctors
will choose those companies
yeah now the other part of this is drug
policy reform
right so that if we make it so you can
buy mdma for 10 or 20 bucks
on your own and we've trained people on
here's our therapeutic method
here is our ways for peer support
then people have an alternative from
buying it from the pharma companies
so most of the for-profit companies
have come to this conclusion that
drug policy reform is bad for their
business model
i think they're making a fundamental
mistake and i think the reason is that
the more that we destigmatize this the
more that we sensitize people to this is
an approach
even when people can get it on their own
and do it with their friends or do it
with themselves
there's going to be even more people
that say oh my god i've got real
serious issues i would rather go to
trained professionals
covered by insurance and i think it'll
increase the business but most
of the for-profit companies don't see it
that way and so
as a non-profit that owns a benefit corp
we're not trying to maximize sales or
profits so that
but but i do believe that drug policy
reform creates this alternative
access point for people and that will
help keep the for profits in check
to some extent as well
i love it
you